what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four but remember one of the
things Jonathan Hickman did is he
shifted it from Fantastic Four to what's
called FF or Future Foundation but
regardless this is the story when Dr
Doom joins the Fantastic Four and he
does it and was probably one of the best
ways ever in Marvel Comics right so
here's the first thing to understand
this all kind of continues so to speak
in the aftermath of the death of Johnny
Storm and the reality here is that with
Johnny being out of the picture the
Fantastic Four are kind of looking for a
new member not so much as a replacement
the idea here is that with everything
that's happened to continue the
Fantastic Four with a replacement member
just kind of seems disrespectful and I
would imagine in a lot of ways this is
Jonathan Hickman kind of hitting on the
John Byrne run the aftermath of really
Secret Wars in 1984 when Ben Grimm left
the team he was replaced by She-Hulk and
so on and so forth and so it's one of
those things where Hickman just kind of
seems to hit this idea that like that's
not really how it's supposed to be and
so what they do and the reason why it
shifts to FF is because it's no longer
the Fantastic Four they no longer call
themselves that instead they now go by
the name Future Foundation and so this
is a really cool theme because what ends
up happening here is that in an effort
to find a new member of the team the
first person they hit up is actually
Spider-Man the reason for this is that
where Peter Parker did initially appear
in Amazing Fantasy Issue Number 15 and
that's where you get its first real
origin and that kind of stuff in
Spider-Man number one he tried to join
the Fantastic Four this was on the
publishing side Marvel's way of
immediately beefing up the popularity of
Spider-Man because the Fantastic Four
were already hot to try and so with them
being like the top publication Marvel
had and then Spider-Man already
exceedingly popular with Amazing Fantasy
number 15. it was a match made in heaven
when they crossed over in the first
issue now of course Spider-Man was
rejected he wasn't really allowed on the
team but over the years in Marvel Comics
one of the things that we've learned is
that Spider-Man in The Fantastic Four
have teamed up for a variety of
circumstances and so in the eyes of the
team it just makes good sense to bring
Peter Parker on board and that's what
they do not everybody's on board with it
for example Ben Grimm isn't really
receptive despite a man being there but
a lot of that's also because Ben grimage
is kind of Coming to Terms to the with
the death of Johnny Storm and the idea
that Peter Parker is kind of a new
person on the team but not really
replacing Johnny just that kind of thing
right it's really been being more angry
with himself than anything else but the
other thing that goes on here is that
with Reed Richard's father Nathaniel
Richards no relation to King the
Conqueror with him showing back up again
for the most part he's going to be a bit
of a background character here he is
going to be involved but you're not
really going to see him see him doing a
whole lot of insane and crazy things but
he becomes incredibly important later on
down the line because there is a piece
of information that he's holding on to
in terms of why all these things are
happening the way they are that we
haven't even seen yet in the story that
will become instrumental later on down
the line now another thing that happens
is that advanced idea mechanics breaks
out the wizard now that's not overly
important for the here and now but it
will be important here in a few minutes
when we kind of move forward and get
Beyond or really get into the story now
one of the other things to remember here
is that Valeria Richards when she was
met by her older self her older self
told her all hope lies in Doom this is
important because what we end up having
after dinner is basically over and it's
just kind of family being family is you
basically have Reed Richards his father
in Valeria who go to meet with Dr Doom
and initially Reed's not overly
receptive to this and it's kind of like
we need him right Valeria and even
Nathaniel stance is like we need Doctor
Doom though and Reed's response is like
I mean no one's going to be on board
with us you do realize if we go to like
Susan and Johnny and Spider-Man we say
hey guys so like Dr Doom is joining the
team they're going to be like absolutely
not none of them are going to be on
board with this but the response of
really Nathaniel and Valeria is but
that's your job at the end of the day
they look up to you and so if you come
along and you say we need Doctor Doom he
has to be on the team they will side
with it they'll do it grudgingly but
they'll do it nonetheless and so that's
ultimately when Doctor Doom is
officially brought to the fan Fantastic
Four now following this and what's
really hilarious things basically unfold
exactly the way you would expect they
would when it's announced to the
Fantastic Four the doctor dreams on the
team not only that Doctor Doom man this
is what this is this is why in Marvel
Comics No One writes Doctor Doom better
than Jonathan Hickman and for those of
you guys who are new to Marvel Comics
this is why fans of Marvel Love Doctor
Doom so much so of course then Graham
freaks out right Benny Graham absolutely
loses it and it's like not a chance no
way this guy's gonna be on the team and
while all this is going on Doctor Doom's
just watching this unfold he's kind of
like you know I mean I bet I could
probably just bust this guy's balls the
whole time so while Ben Grimm is
freaking out Doctor Doom is like is it
true what I've heard Ben is it true that
what I've heard right that when Johnny
Storm died valiantly facing an endless
Army is it true that you surrounded by
crying children Weeping at the
inevitable death of your close comrade
and friend is it true that you just want
watched how very brave
loses it
loses it the self-control goes right out
right out Doctor Doom and Dr Doom can
overcome Ben Grimm quite readily but
then the two of them encounter a force
that neither one is prepared for a
pissed off wife because Susan storm
comes in
shuts them both down right freezes them
both in their place and is like not in
the house and understand Doctor Doom
sure like you're allowed on the team
Victor but if you keep on mouthing off
I'll open a force field inside your
brain that'll basically rupture the
proper brain cells you'll spend the rest
of your days drinking your food through
a straw and drooling so unless you want
to be that guy shut the hell up like
it's just it's crazy right it's just one
of those really really amazing moments
Doctor Doom knows better right Doctor
Doom he's the guy is wildly capable the
guy does all kinds of stuff the one
thing you don't want to mess with is a
pissed off Susan storm and so what goes
on here is kind of this this promise
that was made if you guys recall the
last video that we did that the
agreement that was struck is that Doctor
Doom would help Valeria Richards with a
quest attached that she had if Valeria
Richards would help Doctor Doom regain
his intelligence and so Dr Doom is
brought to the Future Foundation and
it's kind of this funny moment where
literally you have Valeria who's sitting
there and she's already got the answer
she's just trying to see if Dr Doom can
figure it out right she's literally like
okay with everything that's going on
even Peter Parker kind of chimes in
because the Future Foundation doesn't
really know how smart Peter is this guy
immediately makes his intelligence known
when the kids really start asking the
question okay sure we can restore Dr
Doom's intelligence but the ethical
quandary here is should we right because
we bring his intelligence back he goes
right back to Liberia and he starts
going on a quest for Mad levels of power
and all that kind of stuff we're
basically bringing back a villain that
we're gonna have to face off against and
Peter chimes in and he says okay ethics
aside don't you need to determine
whether we're talking about a structural
issue or an actual physical damage or
even just a data issue right like is the
brain biologically sound but it just now
lacks large chunks of information right
and with that kind of Revelation there
it's something they hadn't really
considered is it physical brain damage
he just physically can't access parts of
his brain or is it that parts of his
brain were removed right his own
intelligence basically and that's really
the reality of it pieces of intelligence
were removed and so Valeria kind of
watching all this unfold says okay so
what we need is a backup of doctor
Doom's brain so like literally reads
like did you hear that Victor and he's
like what I'm not really paying
attention and Valeria is like I said we
need a backup and Doom's like yes a
backup and she's like yeah exactly I
said we need a backup and he's like
child you are trying Dooms patience and
they just kind of sit quiet for a second
she's like I said we need a backup
it's moments like these that made
Jonathan Hickman's run so fantastic and
that's when they realize it's Christoph
Bernard now here's one of the things to
keep in mind what we had talked about
previously during Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run here are these these
series of videos is that when it came to
Christoph Bernard he was the adopted son
of Victor Von Doom and he was the heir
for ladveria so when the time came by
whatever Manner and whatever means where
Victor Von Doom died that Kristoff could
continue on and rule the place in his
stead now the other part of this and
probably one of the most genius
decisions made by Dr Doom is that if
something like this were to happen to
him if he were to be put in a position
where he was functioning with diminished
capacity or if his brain was damaged
irreparably or something along those
lines and he created a new host body for
himself or whatever the case may be
Christopher nard was made into a backup
meaning all of Doom's intelligence was
stored inside of Kristoff Bernard and
even Kristoff himself was aware of this
right like he knows what's going on it's
a genius thing to do and so what they
end up doing is hooking him up to a
machine they literally Purge the brain
of Victor Von Doom of everything he
knows and everything that makes him who
he is and then they initiate the
transfer that takes the intelligence
that's stored within Christopher nard
and is placed inside Dr Doom basically
restoring him to his normal self now
here's the thing if something had gone
wrong right if Valeria Richards had been
looking around and then tripped over the
plug and it came out of the wall and the
whole system shut down like literally
you'd be left with a Doctor Doom who's
just in a catatonic State he wouldn't
know anything about anything his brain
wouldn't be able to function he would
basically be one of those lobotomized
versions of Doom that we saw early in
the story that was being captured by the
Council of reads and placed the below
the Citadel and so it's a crazy thing
because following that with this Quest
basically completed now it's time for Dr
Doom to uphold his end of the bargain
and when Reed asks what was it that you
promised Valeria the response of Doctor
Doom is I promise Valeria I would help
her kill you but I would help her
destroy you so let's get on with it in
reality it's destroying the Council of
reeds because here's the thing to know
right the last time we saw the Council
of reads they were fleeing for their
lives from the Mad celestials Valeria
had encountered them when when she
entered the portal but we didn't fully
know what happened what ends up going on
here is that what you actually get is
Valeria and Doctor Doom and these guys
sending out invitations to the most
notable intelligent enemies of Reed
Richards The Thinker the wizard and all
these guys that's why I say under normal
circumstances none of these guys or
anybody to worry about or concern
yourself with but the reality is they
are incredibly intelligent in various
ways and all of them have come fairly
close to being able to defeat Reed
Richards in the Fantastic Four at
different points in time which which
means these are the guys best suited to
basically help destroy the Council of
reeds now the crazy thing about this is
even Reed Richards himself doesn't fully
understand what's going on here all
these plans are being made without him
having the bigger picture in terms of
what's supposed to be happening but in
the middle of this meeting suddenly The
Watcher appears now this is back in a
time in Marvel Comics when the Watchers
showing up actually mattered nowadays
man The Watcher appears and he might as
well be holding a bag of Cheetos and
getting Cheeto dust all over the damn
place like it just doesn't really matter
at all and that's when Reed is like what
have you done Valeria like what have you
done that would lead to the Watcher
appearing with the Assembly of all these
guys here and Valeria spills the beans
on everything now some of this we know
some of this we don't what we do know is
that Valeria reactivated the portal that
Reed Richards had shut down that got him
access to the Council of Reed due to the
fact that the portal could be used by
the Mad celestials to enter into the
main Marvel Universe shutting the portal
down meant the Mad celestials couldn't
enter but we know with Valeria
reactivate in the portal when she got in
there the battle was still raging
between the Council of reeds and the
celestials these Godly powerful
celestials from an alternate reality
that these guys were doing what they
could when they could that Valeria
alongside what was left of the Council
of reads tried to flee and all but four
of them were totally destroyed and that
those remaining four basically ended up
traveling through the portal to
different places around the world and
the gold that they have here is unknown
to us we don't fully understand what
they're doing we simply just know that
they're there but they're not supposed
to be here and given their nature where
they would basically sacrifice and kill
whoever they needed to kill in order to
achieve their goal the concern of
Valeria and even Doctor Doom and Reed
and learning about all this is that
these guys could be a credible threat to
the universe because remember Reed
Richards himself has a universally
relevant intelligence he's the smartest
man in the Marvel Universe now it's more
recent years it's a rule that shifted
between Reed Valeria uh Doctor Doom more
recently as of like the video we made
yesterday blue Marvel Adam year so
they're about the four smartest people
that exist throughout the entirety of
the universe Reeds constructed just
crazy capable things so imagine if
there's four versions of Reed Richards
running around the universe they could
wipe out whole armies that could bring
entire Empires crashing down that could
destroy the universe in its entirety
that's what we're dealing with here
right so again it's a very very
interesting concept because what we end
up doing is picking up several months
after all of this which is to say after
all these guys had passed through this
portal which is about what's going on
right now right so essentially Valeria
passed through the portal and all that
stuff had gone on a few months ago but
the truth about this is that these guys
are each traveling to a different
location one of the first places they
travel to is out to the peak in Old
Atlantis you guys remember that from a
territory and Atlantean Colony that was
discovered that nobody knew about now
this version of read here is actually
designed to gain the trust of a portion
of the old atlanteans by revealing a
traitor within their mist and what this
version of Reed does is actually tell
these guys I can help you eliminate this
threat right eliminate this traitor's
threat that exists out there but I'm
gonna need something in return we don't
know exactly what that thing is but
we'll find out fairly soon the second
read travels to the forever City we
talked about that earlier where it was a
city that was previously created by the
high evolutionary that was designed to
basically jump start the evolution of
everybody on Earth but it ended up going
awry he shut the whole process down and
then basically walked away but the
Ascension engine is what this version of
Reed is after because it's an
astronomical source of power and so as a
result of that this version of Reed
makes a deal with the mole man whose
people have been traveling to the
forever City in order to step into their
next stage of evolution that instead of
the mole men basically regressing and
becoming these exceedingly primitive
life forms they do but their primitive
life forms were actually more advanced
life forms meaning they were more
capable and intelligent at one point in
time and much like people on Reddit they
regressed and they became less
intelligent as time went up and so as a
result of that this guy basically makes
a deal with moleman but we don't find
out exactly what it's for now at that
point we shift over to the blue area of
the Moon with the universal Inhumans now
again kind of re-explaining this a bit
here when it came to the universal
Inhumans what we learned is that where
previously it was believed the Inhumans
on Earth were the only Inhumans that
those in humans survived because of the
Great Purge which meant the cree who
created the Inhumans annihilated pretty
much every inhuman around the universe
they could possibly find due to the fact
that there was a prophecy that the
Inhumans would rise up and destroy the
cree Empire the ones on Earth survived
these Universal Inhumans are others who
survived we simply just didn't know
about it at the time we learned about it
here during Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four run but what goes on here is this
third version of Reed shows up here and
starts making these promises about how
he can help the Inhumans he can help
them achieve their goals and so on and
so forth we don't get like the full-on
description of these terms instead what
ends up happening is one of the leaders
of the Inhumans asked one of the members
to read the mind of this version of read
and that's when they find out he's lie
that basically it's a big ruse here
these different versions of Reed are all
working with these different groups but
they're effectively tricking them and in
order to gain something for themselves
this version of read this his plots
discovered this guy's killed on the spot
like that's it like this guy's destroyed
and so the fourth version of Reed
Richards goes to the to What's called
the other side of zero that nightclub
that we talked about which is still like
one of the best names ever for a
nightclub I feel like if you go there
all they're going to be doing is just
playing like incredibly hardcore
electronic dance music or I don't know
like stuff from like the John Wick
soundtrack but this version of Reed goes
there he meets with the cult the the
leader of the cult of the Negative Zone
which is basically some of annihilus's
forces from the Negative Zone residing
on Earth and that's a big deal because
remember the annihilation wave almost
destroyed the entirety of the universe
so having people who exist on Earth that
can access the Baxter building of the
Fantastic Four and open the portal to
the negative Zone that would create all
kind of problems that's how Johnny Storm
died and so when this version of Reed
meets with this guy he basically speaks
directly to annihilus and says I need
something from you but I realize in
order to get this I'm gonna have to give
you something so what do you need from
me in order for me to get what I need
from you and the response of annihilus
is open the portal to the negative Zone
and keep it open open for the forces of
annihilus open for everything and so
what ends up happening is this exact
thing takes place we end up
transitioning to what is basically the
meeting of all these different versions
of Reed and what we end up finding out
is that what they were constructing is
probably one of the single most
important things that have ever been
made in the history of Marvel Comics
this is an object called Saul's Anvil
now this is when these different plans
and mechanations all start to come
together one of the first things that
happens is you have what's now called
the Council of Doctor Doom right the
Council of Doom which is cool all these
villains meeting together to find a way
to destroy these alternate reality
versions of read and that one of the
things that happens is they all start
thinking like we should destroy them
doing this so we should destroy them
doing that or so on and so forth and a
point that's raised here is that none of
them are thinking about this the right
way and Reed even stands up and says
that he's like yes these men are
versions of me and therefore possess an
intelligence of a similar or in some
instances greater magnitude but they are
also not me they do not have families or
friends they only have each other and
their cause they push worlds around and
rebuild Sons this is much much worse
than any of you could have ever imagined
right like you can't defeat them the way
you would defeat me you can't go after a
Susan storm or a Johnny Storm or Ben
Grimm or Franklin and Valeria you have
to learn to think outside the box you
have to learn to think separately and so
what they start to do is they come to
this realization okay if all these guys
have shown up here and they haven't
launched attack against anybody yet then
what could they possibly be doing what
would Reid do in this situation and the
conclusion they come to is they're
building something they're building a
thing now what they're going to use this
thing for is anybody's guest but they're
using it and what you have is Valeria
who chimes in and says that what they're
building is something called Saul's
Anvil it has something to do with a
machine buried on the moon and there's a
bit with the Negative Zone and some way
to use the Ascension engine in the
forever City and they need a thermal
vent they plan on using the one under
old Atlantis so that's why they're
meeting around with all these different
groups and using all these different
guys that each one of these places
that's why the war of the four cities
was so important each one of these four
places holds a key that will allow these
four versions of Reed Richards to build
this giant construct and to use it for
whatever the purpose happens to be and
so what you end up getting at the same
time this is happening you have Susan
storm who's contacted by old Atlantis
saying we're under attack when she gets
there it's the forces of the mole men
who have been brought by that version of
read or one of the versions of Reed to
basically weed out and destroy those in
Old Atlantis in order to ensure that
another group in Old Atlantis can seize
power it's basically orchestrating a
coup d'etat and so while this battle
Reigns and this whole thing goes on
Susan storm comes face to face with an
alternate alternate version of Reed
Richards and this guy pulls the trigger
on her like literally just shoots her
and destroys her on the spot or at least
incapacitates it doesn't really kill her
but like incapacitates her on the spot
the kick it all this comes in when this
alternate read actually actually
destroys the entire city of old Atlantis
now initially it's seen as a betrayal
but his response is it's necessity
because what he wants is what's under
the city it's a giant thermal van he
doesn't care about anything else out
there right the whole scheme was to
basically sow conflict and allow him to
operate without anybody actually knowing
what he was doing and so with the entire
city being completely and totally
eradicated then their sights turned to
the forever City and so with really
nothing else left to do the Future
Foundation heads back to the Baxter
building where Reed Richards is met with
a pissed off wife and this is Susan
storm angry as she's ever been and the
reason why is because Reed kept all this
from her now here's the thing as a
husband you just don't keep stuff like
that from your wife and you really
shouldn't keep anything from your wife
if anything that's the one person you
can go to to talk about anything
if you're in a marriage and you just
can't talk to your wife about stuff
maybe you're married to the wrong person
right that would be my argument but the
thing about this is that with Reed
having this conversation with Susan and
finally spilling the beans and telling
her what's going on that is her feeling
immensely betrayed but also being able
to focus on the task at hand and saying
okay then let's focus on the thing that
we have to focus on let's take care of
this thing that we have to take care of
now with the forever City things are a
little more diplomatic instead of just
blowing the whole place up right in
order to access what's under it this
version of read actually meets with
those evolved molmen and the thing that
they've been striving for is to actually
be able to procreate themselves it's the
reason why the mole man's molloids have
basically been leaving him and traveling
to the forever City because they kind of
have to right I mean well they they want
to so they can evolve but they're also
being lured there by those who have
evolved what this would do is it would
broker the piece it would basically mean
that the malloy's under Mole Man
wouldn't be lured away from him anymore
he'd be able to stay a king because
after a while I mean if we're being
honest with ourselves who wants to be a
mole man if there's no King that comes
with it right right there's no crown
that comes with it you're literally just
a weird looking guy who lives
underground with a bunch of weird
looking dudes there's no interest in
doing that and so this would allow
things to basically have a peaceful
resolution and it does allow for these
versions of read to quote unquote repair
the machine in order to solve the
problem and then in turn allow this kind
of piece to be brokered where the mole
man keeps his forces the evolved people
stay there and that's basically it but
in the midst of all this suddenly a
giant city starts to appear above the
forever City and when the question
starts being asked okay like what are
the world's going on right like is that
is that old Atlantis like What's
Happening Here the response that's given
is that's a ship of pre-design that is a
ship that has not been on Earth for
quite some time that is the city of
attilan the inhuman royal family has
arrived now as most of you guys know I
don't like Black Bolt this story or
really like Jonathan Hickman's run is
one of the only like one of the three
times ever in the history of Marvel
Comics when black Bolt's ever been cool
or interesting in any real way and you
guys will find out next week because
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace